un concert hommage à johnny hallyday
aura lieu le 14 septembre prochain à
bercy
l'événement organisé par laeticia
hallyday intitulé d'aptitude et que je
t'aime quand les cheveux s'étale comme
un soleil d'été
il réunira nouveaux artistes parmi
lesquels pascal obispo patrick bruel gad
elmaleh douanes ou encore kenji dans la
même journée
la veuve du rockeur devrait également
inauguré avec anne hidalgo l'escaladent
johnny hallyday on dire que laetitia
alors à jamais travaillé depuis quelques
années ça juste en face de la salle une
libération étaient conviés gerin
comprenez ce que vous lisez
non il ya laura smet et ada billets qui
seront habités
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon ça veut dire qu'il y aura du monde
sur route ou sur ma merde alors juste
aujourd'hui à paniquer car les impôts là
tu t'y tard le concert sera diffusé sur
france 2 mais en prime sans animateur
c'est pas vrai qu'en mai france 2 ans
preneur sans animateur merci est ce
qu'une journée hommage national à johnny
pour vous c'est c'est eh bien oui bien
sûr ça fait plaisir à tous et on a vu ce
budget comme il a fait bercy il à
l'européenne plus de 100 fois sur une
fois je sens une force en une fois non
sans une fois croyait plus que dorothée
ah oui ben ouais c'est le record à
battre est d'amener vos côtés oui oui
j'ai un peu l'impression quand même que
ça devient une opération politique du
maire de paris de la maire de paris anne
hidalgo va voir on va voir un de ses
conseillers tout à l'heure alors je
voulais pas qu'ils adulent une
initiative formidable
[Applaudissements]
mais les jaunes je trouve que c'est
formidable également c'est vraiment
formidable
c'est vrai c'est une figure française il
ya des places avec des noms de peintres
avec des noms de poètes pas un artiste
de la chanson je suis bien sûr donc du
coup ce serait johnny alors vos six mois
je vous dirais et vous savez connaissez
l'histoire victor hugo stade yens la
tienne oui oui vous savez que victor
hugo je crois que victor hugo habitées
oui avenue c'est le seul salut sinon de
son vivant tout à fait et web et les
religions sont la venue voir exactement
il est pareil quand il a envoyé des
qualités en son avenir cieux ouais ben
voyons mais on son impasse non mais
c'est pas grave on apprend des choses
cette émission on n'est pas répandue